to be calm is the highest achievement of
the self
he who has the most is he who is content
with the least
to be even-minded is the greatest virtue
the future lies in uncertainty live in
the present
it does not matter what you bear but how
you bear it
a gem cannot be polished without
friction nor a man perfected without
trials
self-control is strength
right thought is mastery calmness is
power
man conquers the world by conquering
himself
be stoic do the right thing
keep going
success is based on your willingness to
work hard no matter what obstacles you
may encounter
when someone is properly grounded in
life they shouldn't have to look outside
themselves for approval
the ultimate power in life is to be
completely self-reliant
learn to be indifferent to what makes no
difference
to bear trials with a calm mind rob's
misfortune of its strength and burden
[Music]
the willing are led by fate the
reluctant dragged
[Music]
too many people believe that everything
in life must be pleasurable
a rational person can find peace by
cultivating indifference to the things
outside of their
control relentlessly prune the useless
don't put off doing things that matter
savor the time you have
a stoic is a buddhist with attitude
master your mind don't be mastered by it
[Music]
if you are easily provoked you are
easily controlled
[Music]
the more you seek the uncomfortable the
more you will become comfortable
[Music]
between stimulus and response there is a
space
in that space is our power to choose our
response
if it's endurable endure it stop
complaining
failure and deprivation are the best
educators
[Music]
that's what stoicism is all about
learning to live a good life by
developing peace of mind through
confidence in one's ability to overcome
adversity
the first rule is to keep an untroubled
spirit
the second is to look things in the face
and know them for what they are
the wise man is neither raised up by
prosperity nor cast down by adversity
for always he has driven to rely
predominantly on himself
and to derive all joy from himself
[Music]
the greatest law of nature is that it
never stops there is no end
don't explain your philosophy live it
i love to go and see all the things i am
happy without
[Music]
stoicism is about the control of
emotions not their elimination
[Music]
waste no more time arguing what a good
man should be
be one
wealth consists not in having great
possessions but in having few wants
you have power over your mind not
outside events
realize this and you will find strength
that which gives light must endure
burning
what we fear doing most is usually what
we most need to do
i begin to speak only when i'm certain
what i'll say isn't better left unsaid
be tolerant with others and strict with
yourself
[Music]
having the fewest wants i am nearest to
the gods
[Music]
no human thing is of serious importance
you do not choose your problems you
choose how you react to them
the obstacle is the way
great times are great softeners
what we desire makes us vulnerable
the limit is not the sky the limit is
the mind
[Music]
uncertainty is an uncomfortable position
but certainty is an absurd one
discomfort is the currency of success
show people don't tell them
to complain of reality is always
unacceptable
if it doesn't challenge you it won't
change you
don't aim to be perfect
aim to be indestructible
[Music]
you will be attacked for doing the right
thing
do it anyway
[Music]
you amplify everything you react to
there is no genius without a touch of
madness
keep your intentions pure emotions will
try to distract you keep going that's
the cure
do what you will
even if you tear yourself apart most
people will continue to do the same
things
it can ruin your life only if it ruins
your character
otherwise it cannot harm you inside or
out
in life it doesn't matter what happens
to you or where you came from
it matters what you do with what happens
and what you've been given
make the mind tougher by exposing it to
adversity
we should not like sheep follow the herd
of creatures in front of us
making our way where others go
not where we ought to go
welcome each day as the very best day of
all make it your own seize it before it
flees
[Music]
inwardly we should be different in every
respect
but our outward dress should blend in
with the crowd
we are quick to forget that just being
alive is an extraordinary piece of good
luck a rare event
a chance occurrence of monstrous
proportions
difficulty is what awakens genius
very little is needed to make a happy
life
it is all within yourself in your way of
thinking
[Music]